[Music]
we are another day closer to Avengers
infinity war and with each day closer
that we get we get a new theory these
range anywhere from who's going to die
to where the soul stone is or to which
characters are gonna pop up in the films
that we haven't seen yet some of you
have been asking me for my opinions on
the theories that are out there so in
this video we'll be going over the
theories and the probability of them
happening before we dive into those
theories if you're not doing anything
else while watching this video go ahead
and click that little red subscribe
button oh no finish your tweet that's
fine just give us a second go get her
tiger
also spoiler alert I'm not sure if any
of these theories are true but there are
a lot in here so the likelihood of one
at least being true is good okay first
theory and I warn you this one is
probably true so it is your last chance
to turn away and that is that Loki will
betray Thanos and will most likely be
killed yes this is definitely going to
happen
the next theory is that the mutants will
be revealed and the x-men will enter the
same universe as the Avengers due to the
Disney Fox merger this probably
definitely will not happen due to the
merger falling through theory number
three danos will bring red school back
this could happen
many believe that red school is not dead
but in fact use the tesseract to
teleport to somewhere else in the
universe
maybe Thanos could bring him back if he
needs him don't really think he does
theory number four Justin Hammer will
return no theory number five Captain
Marvel will appear in affinity war very
unlikely scene as her movie doesn't come
out until after Infinity Ward but she
will definitely be in Avengers for
theory number six Shuri will become the
new Iron Man haven't heard this one
before it's an interesting concept and
could be possible but we'll see theory
number seven Bucky Barnes will become
the new Captain America wrong he do edge
woof theory number eight Sam Wilson
becomes the new Captain America this is
very likely not to mention this actually
happens in the comics theory number nine
what happens to Captain America in the
movie Theory number ten let's just back
it up a moment
alright guys he dies we know this
already
but there is an alternative theory to
this which is theory number ten that
Steve Rogers will go back in time and
live happily ever after with Peggy
Carter this is very unlikely to happen
given that the Russo brothers have
already stated that they won't really be
bringing anybody back to life if they
die but at the end they could get a hold
of the Infinity Gauntlet and make it
happen
theory eleven Steve Rogers will lift
mule near mule near is not even in the
movie so it sounds like he had a pretty
special and intimate relationship with
this hammer and then losing that was
almost comparable to losing a loved one
it's a nice way of putting it theory
number twelve Hulk is in the Hulkbuster
well I think it probably starts off as
Bruce Banner and then once he gets
defeated the Hulk gets super angry and
busts out and then then the Hulk's in
the hold buster okay so the next
theories are on the soul stone
so theories 13 14 15 16 17 18 and 19
ready here we go
the soul stone is in Wakanda it's in
you start it's inside Heimdall it's
inside the Red Planet from the trailer
it's with Adam warlock it is not in the
movie and last but not least Captain
Marvel is actually trapped inside of the
soul stone one of these is probably true
if you wanna know more click on this
link dearie number 20 Korg starts
another revolution and defeats Thanos
revolution this is it I'm calling it
right now this is how Thanos dies
someone's not counting well that's it
for some of the theories that we've
heard surrounding Avengers infinity war
what do you guys think about these
theories and have you heard any other
crazy theories yourselves let me know
the comments below I just may throw them
into my next video
sure to give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to my channel so you don't
upset baby group thank you so much for
watching Wolfgang wolf wolf
[Music]
you